heard of the save ima norway masjid
project your brothers and sisters at
islam that are establishing a one of his
kind masjid tawa and community center in
the capital of norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts islam through this center every
revert who learns about their deen and
calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video assalamu
alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
i'm here with prophet muhammed
not bad
god's good yeah alhamdulillah we know
you're not bad you know we saw those
jobs there and there's no hooks you know
is the guy still alive
this might be a coma but today we're
going to have a different intellectual
karma brother sisters we are going to be
not reacting but there's a tweet of
somebody called young don so young don
is i don't even know who he is obviously
i don't know who he is uh but to be
honest he went from young don to young
khan why because he had a few
discussions with uthman as well
and i think he kind of
intellectually uh was
i mean educated let's say educated so he
when he went to say the following okay
so basically after being intellectually
educated um that trinity doesn't make
sense and right different other things
here's what he had to say so i'll spend
all day today watching
david wood and nabil koreshi the baited
muslims are pointless what i got to say
is before you consider following islam
just do a little research from the
people i just mentioned basically okay
after that so basically he made a
youtube comment as well after he was
invited by the the three muslim brothers
or something like that it didn't go well
for him you know but if you have a
belief christianity on the trinity oh
it's not gonna go well so it goes bro i
don't care if you respect me i won't be
i won't be your judge when you die you
worship a false religion founded by a
man that um
the nine-year-old girl yeah i never
claimed to be a biblical scholar but
quite frankly i don't need to be in in
order to preach the gospel i did not
come to debate you muslim friends but to
rather learn but in true nature of the
song many of these muslim teachers he is
more fixated on trying to treat
treat me up using mental traps and
tricks that he is used a thousand times
instead of discussing the matter at hand
so this is not follow okay so
the question i want to ask is why would
a christian who has an intellectual
discussion and it doesn't go to plan
because of his
belief system why do they become so
bitter why do we have to resort to ad
hominems and attacks and not only that
actually suggest people like
rotten wood and his legs who desecrate
and rip the quran
i mean what does that tell you about the
person i don't know about this guy but i
i don't think i want to uh by the fans
of it this individual
obviously call him young don
you know he's dealing with the real don
actually the champion uh alidao
[Laughter]
and uh
look i mean
you know
what's his point what does he okay it's
very very simple okay
he's got nothing the reason i mention
him is because i want to just a specific
point
his claim is very simple okay he got
intellectually rinsed he's upset by it
he's emotional about it so his argument
back is what your prophet married aisha
at nine or uh did whatever et cetera so
his claim is this islam can't be true
we were talking about the trinity and
that was
that's how he resorted
well that would seem to be material but
that's a
[Laughter]
it's my criteria
if his claim is if the premise is this
your islam is false because the prophet
muhammad um married isis 9 and he
believes that to be moral okay yes
please go ahead please okay if his claim
is that the premise is your fault islam
is false because your prophet married
ash at night and he believes that's
immoral okay
fine no problem let's go with the
argument that that on that basis the
prophet muhammed cannot be a true
prophet peace be upon him and therefore
islam is false no problem let's apply it
to the bible do we have to be consistent
consistent well if you wanna be okay no
problem okay if you're gonna be a
christian in this okay do you you you
the christians that you speak to they
agree that jesus is god right yes they
do do they accept that jesus is the god
of the old testament yes they do okay do
they agree that in the book of numbers
correct yeah in which
it's chapter 31 verse 18. okay so what
does it say there by the way when you
refer to it please refer to it not god
of the old testament as jesus saying so
what did jesus command well i mean the
reason why we're saying that jesus said
it is clearly because if you believe in
a triune god yes then we believe that
that is is the author of the old
testament then jesus is part of that
right
and so for example when it says take the
young
ones
for yourself or the
you know the the hebrew words uh taf
okay uh
you know so you can take it for yourself
i'm liking the hebrew by the way i'm
like i'm not sure
it's like arabic
so who's this order being given to by
jesus yes it's uh
moses to the amalekites so let me get
this right so jesus the god of the old
testament is ordering moses who is a
prophet
does a christian accept him as a prophet
yeah when he did this act is he still a
prophet yeah okay so let me get this
right so jesus of the old testament
which is god is commanding moses who is
a prophet and while he's doing this act
of keeping the little ones for himself
he's still a prophet they don't deny his
prophethood well absolutely okay but but
when it comes to the prophet muhammad
who didn't do this act which you're
talking about because here the hebrew
the rabbis actually say that this might
be talking about a three-year-old child
well absolutely this is a good point
you're making about the rabbis because
the talmud you know for example the
palestinian talmud is referred to thusly
not because
of palace new palace this is talking
about an ancient document palestine
still existed at the time the jewish
palestinian talmud it's not not made up
israel no we're talking about you know
something the jewish jewish people
believed
uh it was clearly saying that you could
this is talking about uh slavery is
talking about taking uh prepubescence
for yourself uh and in fact let me read
something just because some people will
be thinking that this is maybe some kind
of uh islamic apologetics okay so it
might be for example the theological
bible commentary uh samuel valentine
states uh the following
he says that those who have not known a
man by sleeping with him 31 18 of
numbers must be spared
the text does
specify the text does specify he states
uh what keeping them alive
for
for yourself means what does it mean but
we may reasonably assume from other
legislation
concerning the treatment of women
captured in war and he mentions
deuteronomy chapter 21 verses 10 to 14
that sparing their lives opens
possibilities that may be
incorporated into israelite community
and upon marriage
to an israelites being granted full
citizenship if his claim is that the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him
cannot be a true prophet because of
something he deems to be immoral no
problem if we apply the set same thing
there because there's a prophet and
there's god almighty which is more
higher your god of the old testament
which is jesus who
are stipulated
moses to carry out this action of
keeping the little girls after killing
people for himself and he was still a
prophet you don't reject his prophethood
and if that's the case then you need to
say bye to jesus you need to reject your
god out right if this is your condition
because if this is your condition that
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
married aisha and constipated at nine
then what's happening here is worse
therefore
absolutely you need to you need to free
yourself from christianity absolutely
because
if consistently if what he's saying is
that if what he's opposed to is taking
virgins young ones uh taf or the hebrew
all these kind of things uh if he sees
that as a moral aberrations abhorrent is
uh yeah totally incorrect yes
then i would say to him
that his god was the major facility
master facilitator such disrespect and
dissertation to the young ones
his god was the was master facilitated
such a desecration to the young ones
exactly which means uh not only was he
participating in such action actually i
would say much more i would say that his
god his god was
was allowing moralizing legitimizing
validating such action uh so that many
men could uh enjoy the young ones in the
way that so i don't know what this man
is talking about if he says well then
because there could be a
counter-argument he could say well jesus
came and he revoked the law you see
even though he said i shall not come and
revoke you of the of the of the relevant
of the prophets at one point he did he
stipulated who cares exactly so the
point is is it conceivable
at any point in time historically that
your god jesus christ and the triune yes
uh formulation of the trinity yes that
he he he indulged in facilitating such a
thing in any time so you're telling me
that there could be a time yes where
such action could be uh proper yes
exactly so that's disgraceful what was
stipulated to happen to them
your god allows this little one so the
little ones and let's speak to the
younger ones
the other ones being raped the young
ones
college students merch too
i mean that's it young don i think you
know this is more than enough for you
it's more than enough for you i think
this capsule here this little pill this
little prescription that we gave you is
more than enough for you and your
youtube channel listen yeah you're
you're a con yes that's what you want
you're khan he's a con
last words are look i mean i don't think
he has much to master by way of
intellectual fortitude or physical uh
uh fortitude
i think he's
intellectually conversationally bankrupt
and i do think that he's run out of
bullets
uh if his christianity that he's trying
to defend i think he's doing a poor job
in doing so
referencing his masters who have already
had my way with
decapitated intellectually absolutely i
i think that i think he admires us bro
he does he must do he does
look i mean he how could he not
[Laughter]
this is the question i mean
answer this question forget about all
the religions you're not good at that he
said it himself he's not a scholar he's
not anything
how
how could you not admire yeah yes ali
dawa
how could you not admire her
he's everything you've ever wanted to be
you need to be careful he's everything
you ever wanted to be as a child we have
muslims that defend defend the enemies
of islam
let's be careful let's be careful he's
he's everything you ever wanted to be as
a child you know yes
he's engaged in normal activities he's
influential normal activities yes
there's been some paranormal activities
who believes in the true religion come
on so i mean that's it that's not let's
wrap it up here from mohammad alidawah
to yangcon uh can you do your finish
time please officially
have you heard of the save ima norway
masjid project your brothers and sisters
at islam that are establishing a one of
his kind masjid tawa and community
center in the capital of norway and they
need our urgent support now every person
that accepts islam through this center
every revert who learns about their deen
and calls their family to the worship of
allah you will get the rewards inshallah
click the button to donate and earn this
tremendous reward inshallah and don't
forget to share the video